[音楽]
の
[拍手]
re
はい
ファッションと地域個性
今グローバル社会においてこの2つはとても大きな要素
持っています
かつて世界中民族衣装というフィルターを通して地域個性に溢れていました
現在洋服の時代が来ていこう
その地域個性というのは少しずつ
少しずつちっちゃくなっています
都市を構成する要素は3つ
いい
続中です
とりわけ位の文化というのは育ちにくく
今ではスーパーブランドがファストファッションも大きな意見を占められています
では
これから先
小資本の若手がどのようにして立ち向かっていけばいいのか
さらに地域に沿って生きていくにはファッションブランドが活躍するにはどうしたら
いいのか
学生さんはお金がないという cm が少し前にはやっ流行りました
ファッショングラウンドも実はお金がないんです
ゼロから一応上に出す素晴らしい人たちがお金に困ってしまう
その問題を皆さんで僕は解決したい
僕は中学生の時
体罰の厳しい学校になじめず
自律神経失調症に陥って不登校になってしまいます
そんな時たまたま見た nba の試合でマイケルジョーダンという選手をしています
彼のはく奇抜なスニーカーに心奪われたんです
エアジョーダンということでした
そのエアジョーダンにあわせるアメリカンがファッションに
心を打たれます
僕は
ファッション雑種をとにかく読みあさりました
そしていつか自分のブランドを持ちたいという夢を抱くんです
しかし
僕が
槍じゃやりたいやりたいと言っても
ファッションの夢は簡単ではありません
皆がやってみたい
だから競争率も高いその上泊単位のお金がかかる
冷静な音がたちは
より無理無理無理やめとけ
と僕に言うんです
なぜ
こんなにも心からやりたいよ
その辛い経験からこのように思いました
地域みんなに
支援してもらったらいいんじゃないかと
地域の人たちに
育ててもらったらいいんじゃないかと
育てるとはファッションブランドファミリーのように思ってもらっているんです
家族のように自分の薄このように結べの良い
今ファッションにお金を使うという風潮が馬鹿げてる
と無駄じゃないお金がっていう雰囲気が今世の中に漂っています
ですがこれが自分の子供に対してお金を投資する
あこのブランドいいよねこいつら地域の代表だからさせてあげなきゃね
ちょっと高いけど買ってあげようよっていう風に思えば
きっとそれが地域個性の未来に繋がると僕は思うのです
何個か例を挙げてみましょう
まずは着物
皆さん気ままを買うときはとての高くて勇気がいると思うんです
しかし
黄色のカッターととても大切にしようと思います
それは着物というものが皆さんの幼い頃から大切なものだと日本という国を代表する
アイデンティティの一つであるということを自分たちの心の奥底で知ってるからです
世界中の文化伊佐地車
修道院
他意はない信仰心によって皆さんの心のよりどころになってるはずです
あ何かあるとあそこに行こうを前にシュッしに行こ
そういった心は自分たちに深いところで精神的に結びついているはずです
地域を代表する料理食材
そういったものは
地域を大切にしようと思う若手の両輪によって文化を交流させながらも
さらに新しいテントを生み出そうとしています
ファッションも僕はそのレベルまでいけると思うんです
深い先進的な部分でず流れると思うんです
では具体的にどうしたらいいんでしょうかまずは場所を確保するということです
若手のクリエイターの作品は実は僕場所がなかなかありません
まずは地域のどこかで
場所を借りる
年からネジを受けては言いませんいろんなところで持ち回りをすればいいと思うんです
そうすることで経験というものがもあります
体験ができます
ファーストんというものは体験を通してさらに深い理解を得ることができます
そして感動を生みますあこの記事は綺麗だね
今週レットは綺麗だね着心地いいよねそういった経験が感動生んでいきますそうする
ことで次に
デザイナーの個性を知ってます
デザイナーの個性が分かるとそのブランドをもっともっと知りたいという気持ちになっ
てきます
デザイナーの個性がわかればあこのグランドもっと育てていきたいよね
自分にはグランドはこの人だよねっていう風になってきます
今個人の発信力というのはメディアを超えさらに強くなっています
握手会やサイン会そういった経験も含めて
メディアで今のアイドルのように発信しても
それはとても重要な要素であるといいます
最後に国際空港における
免税店の
改良を提案したい
今世界中どの空港に行っても免税店は似たような光景です
フランスイタリアやイギリスここ日本でも
どこもかしこも見た光景です
もしフランスに皆さんがについて
フランスの空港のど真ん中に
メインストリートのど真ん中にラーメン屋さんがあったらどうでしょう
ちょっと違和感を感じると思いませんか
ちょっと僕たちがフランスに行った時に求めるものっていうのは伝統的なフランス料理
であったり
クロワッサンとカプチーノといった朝食だったりすると思うんです
イタリアであればアッツアツのピザに方向なカルボナーラ
そういったものをみなさんイメージするんじゃないかと思うんです
空港という場所はウエルカムだな場所であり
グッパイな場所でもあります
その場所の免税店のど真ん中に地場のブランドをドーンと置いていただきたい
きっと
観光客は
とても
エキサイティングな教師になると思いますわくわくすると思います
そのわくわく感こそが地場の二ラウンドの
未来を生み結果海
地域と
さらに密着した光景につながると僕は信じています
今日はご静聴ありがとうございました
ああありがとうございます
[拍手]
2 ldk フラワーん